salut !! salut aujourd'hui on est au parc de Belleville .
et je suis pas tout seul,
je suis avec Julie !
On s'est rencontré dans des trains
parce que je fais des evenementiels avec le spectacle
et c'est julie qui s'en occupe
c'est un train que vous connaissez mais j'ai pas le droit de dire quel train c'est.
c'est en 4 lettres.mais j'ai pas le droit de le dire
est ce que tu peux penser a un sigle.
n'importe quel sigle ? dans le monde.
ça peux être pour le coup RATP, URSAAF.... -"Mais en rapport avec des trains ? "
non pas du tout
...URSSAF, tu vois ce que je veux dire, tu choisis quelque chose. ou une marque
même une marque si tu veux. - "D'accord"
mais tu me dis pas laquelle
okay
donc une marque potentiellement je la connais ?
tu penses que je la connais ?
ou tu es sûre que je l'a connais ?
-"si je pense que tu la connais ?"
d'accord c'est genre aussi connue que coca quoi
ouais
est ce que c'est connu dans d'autres pays ?
oui
est-ce que tu va me donner tous les indices quand je te poserai des questions ?
vu que tu me les poses oui
non mais c'est bien,c'est bien
je vais commencer par quoi ?
je vais commencer par chercher dans quel secteur il s'applique
d'accord
je vais dire plein de chose je vais affirmer des choses
tu me donnes pas d'indices
tu me réponds pas si c'est juste ou faux
tu me dis rien
je dis rien du tout ?
tu dis rien du tout
j'écoute juste ce que tu dis ?
exactement
ça peut être dans le secteur de l'alimentaire ?
du quotidien pour tout le monde ?
beaucoup plus institutionnel ?
ça peut être lié au service ?
ça peut être lié à l'administration ?
ça peut être lié au transport ?
je vais essayer de choper la première lettre
tu penses à la 1er lettre tu cherches pas à me donner d'indices
ça peut être une consonnes ? une voy... c'est une consonne ? c'est juste ?
oui, d'accord
okay, tu penses à la consonne
ça peut être a-b-c-d-e-f-h-i-j-k-l-n-m-o. J-K-L--N-M-O-P-Q-R-S-T-U-V-W-X-Y-Z.
d'accord j'ai 2 endroits ou ça match
... rire... je vais peut-être écrire les deux
pour l'instant j'ai le r et le z
d'accord. on va passer sur le nombre de lettres
à chaque fois que je claque des doigts, tu épelles une lettre dans ta tête .
ah oui dans ma tête
par exemple si c'est a,b,c. tu fais A*clac* B*clac* C*clac* etc ...
c'est parti ?
*clec* *clec* *clec* *clec* *clec*
c'est terrible. Là vous le voyez pas, j'aurais dû mettre la go pro aussi
parce que tu as les lèvres qui font un peu de mouvements en fait .
et donc du coup je sais que c'est z
Ok !!
et c'est 4 lettres
Non ?
-"je dis rien toujours ?" "dis rien si tu veux, je pense que j'l'est
est ce que tu peux leur dire à quelle marque tu pensais ?
à Zara
ah Zara bien sûr
ah bravo
merci julie. ça ta plus ? oui. cool on se retrouve bientôt dans un train
on dira pas le nom mais qui à 4 lettres, - "pas de soucis . Bah salut"
oui parce que d'habitude je fais l'actu des gens mais là...
non tu fais pas mon actu,
julie son numéro de téléphone c'est le 06. NON ça tu te tais
alors vous retrouvez le numéro de téléphone dans le descriptif de la vidéo
si cette vidéo vous a plu, si Julie vous a plue .vous pouvez le faire savoir en mettant un pouce en l'air
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo je me ferai un plaisir de lire et de répondre à vos questions
pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog !!!
ciao !!!